it's still not clear if Japanese
authorities in their search of Goins
residents found anything to explain how
he slipped through the net in the
Lebanese capital of Beirut though camera
crews have laid siege to the home of the
former Nissen chairman after his arrival
there go and explained that he believed
the Japanese court system was unjust and
that his arrest had been politically
motivated goons seen here in archival
footage plans to speak to journalists
next week Lebanon has now received an
official request from Interpol to arrest
him as a fugitive but neighbors don't
believe he's a criminal he did help
misson and Renault to achieve this
statute yes as a businessman he did well
indeed as a Lebanese man we're proud of
him
journalist Ricardo Karim is a close
friend of Carlos gone he spoke to him
after his escape if the cumshaw live
near he was confident about the future
he's got a lot of plans and that's the
most important thing he's surrounded by
his family and friends he's at home here
in his country he knows compete
guns escaped to Lebanon is a stunning
twist in a roller-coaster journey that
saw him fall from boardroom to detention
centre here he spent more than 100 days
in Spartan conditions far removed from
his sometimes extravagant lifestyle the
auto tycoon stands accused of unreported
his salary to the tune of 85 million
dollars prosecutors also allege he
skimmed off millions of dollars from the
company for his personal use Tokyo has
no extradition treaty with Beirut
Japan's Justice Department is left
holding Goins bond worth around 12
million euros